laboratoire de pasteur marcel mérieux il
paraissait en 1937 laissant à son fils
charles un lourd héritage un passé
familial à respecter et à l'avenir à
forger notre caméra q quel a été votre
père vraiment faire et être un savant ce
qui était l'élève de ses pasteurs et un
artiste aussi et j beast lyonnais il
était en allemagne lorsque monsieur
pasteur a demandé à un jeune français
parlant allemand
c'est ainsi qu'il était l'assistant
personnel du dr ou à la cie du pasteur à
l'époque historique et qu'il devait
créer la saint-michel le premier n'a pas
entre d'analysés français sous le
patronage de la cie du pasteur mais mon
grand père et ses amis nous refuser des
15000 francs nécessaires à ce
laboratoire
c'est ainsi qu'il a échoué à lyon fait
échouer pour à vaise enfin du sérum
d'affaires pur peral pour le compte des
usines du rhône oui quand on revient à
ses sources et toutefois et après cet
échec complet de cette thérapeutique il
à mentir les chiffres de berre son
premier laboratoire où il fait de la
musique parce qu'il a même qu'à trois
opéras une affaire énorme mais surtout
il a introduit la biologie médicale à
lyon et c'est ainsi que son ami le
risque et internes des hôpitaux en ce
moment la ramener tous les patrons de
l'hôpital suivent les cours de mon père
ou chine libère marcel mérieux avec un
important aspect assez strict avec vous
souvenir
bien sûr j'ai connu mon père a cité un
salaire de bon j'en ai déjà entendu
temps et c'est toujours le même et on
peut dire si au microscope il faisait
lui-même toutes les analyses les plans
médical lyonnais sera par l ue27
tuberculine trois heures de musique
il ya eu dans dix ans la chine a eu
trois étapes l'étape pasteurienne
politique historique
l'étape navires au logis du strike et
qui était dû au développement de la
fièvre aphteuse on appelait ça tellement
c'est la seul endroit on n'a plus une
première place mondiale mais c'est cette
activité vétérinaire qui nous a permis
de former des équipes qui ont mis au
point le vaccin contre le viol par
exemple et la poliomyélite et la
troisième étape c'est celle du surmotive
sociétaires et 10000
j moderne et qui également s'inscrit
dans ce contexte scientifique mais se
développe surtout sur une orbite mondial
lui de l'ogive tient à sa part dans un
passé industriel et le pari que desertec
rhône poulenc c'est de conserver mon
indépendance moral et scientifique tout
en prenant développement international
en méditerranée ainsi pratiquement
décidé puisque sur une base paritaire et
mondial byron poulenc nous ont demandé
de coordonner les efforts et terrena du
groupe et en médecine humaine dont je
souhaite de vraiment avec enthousiame
qu'avec la cie pasteur ont réalisé une
unité qui permette d'assistance
technique française de rendre au pays de
pasteur sa première place dans mon
d'octane à vue il serait bon maintenant
d'évoquer les rapports de l'institut
avec les hôpitaux y tient
essentiellement par tradition est pas
raison l'exemple du démonstratif
c'est la maison polonaise du sirop
nantis capacité qui est une première
mondiale
très important dans polonais d'élèves
d'organes or nous avons travaillé que
profession carraz du pasteur profession
très cher des hospices civils de lyon